il pleut depuis six mois pratiquement
sans interruption sur le perron des
pluies qui provoquent des inondations
catastrophiques dont on n'a que très peu
parlé jusqu'à présent document que nous
allons vous montrer est donc l'un des
tout premiers films et sur le terrain
mais raison de ces inondations
s'explique très scientifiquement il
s'agit d'un phénomène naturel qui
revient tous les dix ou douze ans appelé
le niño l'enfant en espagnol parce qu'il
commence aux environs de noël et durant
suite de six à huit mois ce n'est pas à
proprement parler ainsi claude mais
plutôt une sorte de mousson des pluies
diluviennes ininterrompues dans la cause
reste encore l hymne expliqué bernard
benyamin la région de piura dans le nord
du pérou à environ 700 km de la capitale
cataclysme naturel pour les uns
malédiction divine pour les autres
depuis le début de l'année en tout cas
ce sont des pluies diluviennes qui
s'abattent sur cette région
des pluies comme on n'en a jamais vu et
qui transforme certains mots en
véritable île artificielle noyant sous
des trombes d'eau des milliers
d'hectares de terres cultivées on ne
compte plus les morts et disparus
les villages engloutis les éboulements
l'église quand terrain les routes
coupées les sans abri bien sûr et cela
fait six mois qu'ils n'en finit pas de
pleuvoir
maintenant il n'y a plus que dieu qui
puisse nous venir en aide des
communications difficiles
une mauvaise appréciation de la
situation au départ l'extrême
éloignement de ses provinces
tout cela explique l'indifférence dans
laquelle ce drame s'est joué
une femme d'origine française revient
des lieux de la catastrophe
elle témoigne et lance un appel à la
solidarité internationale
il y à des villages de 1000 ou 2000
habitants qui n'ont absolument aucun
aliment aucun moyen d'en obtenir qui
marche quatre jours à pied d'allers et
de retours pour essayer d'obtenir un sac
de riz
malheureusement le perron essaye de
lutte et le gouvernement
unis en marge des actions tout à fait
valable et mal à se lancer déjà à peu
près combien de victimes ces inondations
ont fait au pérou malheureusement il n'y
a pas de chiffres exacts encore parce
qu'il ya des endroits où les gens sont
si malheureux qu'ils n'ont même pas un
cercueil à donner à leurs enfants et
leurs enfants sont entrés
clandestinement
il n'y a donc pas encore de chiffres
officiels ce sont les enfants qui
représentent 60% de la population de
cette région spécifique du pérou qui
sont les plus atteints en particulier au
niveau d'épidémie invraisemblable de
malaria de paludisme même de peste parce
que lorsqu'on pense inondations pense
que l'eau est un élément pur
malheureusement bout de six mois
c'est l'enfer donc c'est toute une
région entière qui est recouverte par
les eaux qui complètement paralysé et
complètement isolé parce que toute la
route panaméricaine qui est donc le
moyen de la relier aussi bien au corps
qu'on ville qui pourrait apporter du
secours
malheureusement tout est interrompue les
portions de routes qui ont pu être
reconstruites sont à nouveau détruite et
c'est pourquoi il faut naturellement
tout une sorte d' équipements sur tous
les plans et toute une reconstruction
intégrale qui est au dessus des moyens
et péruviennes du gouvernement péruvien
précisément que peut faire le
gouvernement péruvien dans cette affaire
le gouvernement à l'heure actuelle
distribuer des rations alimentaires aux
enfants on ne l'envoie pas d'aliment on
leur donne des aliments déjà préparé de
façon à éviter tout tout marché noir des
aliments qui pourraient être données
malheureusement il est impossible de de
faire ce qu'il faut pour pour toute
cette population il y a trois milliards
et demi de nouveaux francs de dégâts
et alors que nous que peut faire
l'occident que peut faire l'europe et la
france en particulier la france au
niveau je pense du gouvernement pourrait
très certainement apporter beaucoup en
équipement en médicaments en médecins
tous les français pourrait participer en
donnant quelques france supposerait des
rations un tiers d'aliments pour des
enfants des rues lien
il y a opéré une économie différente de
la nôtre ce qui est l'abondance d'un
côté c'est malheureusement la mort très
lente mais précieux